the actor who portrays Bruce Lee and
once upon a time in Hollywood has broken
his silence about the recent backlash if
he still haven't seen Quentin
Tarantino's latest film be warned there
are some major spoilers ahead shortly
after the July 26th world premiere of
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood Bruce
Lee's daughter Shannon sharply
criticized the film's portrayal of her
late legendary father
Shannon Feld the movie made a mockery
out of the martial arts master tying the
rap that Quentin Tarantino made him look
like in arrogance all he was full of hot
air the controversial scene in question
involves a fight between Bruce Lee and
Brad Pitt's character stuntman cliff
Boothe a scuffle that eventually finds
Boothe shoving Lee against the side of a
car anybody accidentally kills anybody
and fight they go to jail it's called
manslaughter in an interview with both
movies death mike mode the actor who
portrays Bruce Lee revealed he had some
major issues of the first version of the
once upon a time in Hollywood scripts
I'm not going to tell you what the
original script had exactly but when I
read it I was so conflicted because he's
my hero Bruce in my mind was literally a
guard he wasn't a person to me he was a
superhero and I think that's how most
people view Bruce but Moe firmly
believes Tarantino has a lot of respect
for Bruce Lee the actor points out that
Lee didn't actually lose the fight it
was technically a tie if you've seen the
film you're a member that Lee wins the
first round and loses a second the
battle has broken up before the winner
can be determined in a third round Moe
also makes a point to say the thing
about it is number one it's a Tarantino
film he's not going to do the thing that
everybody expects anybody else to do
you've got to expect the unexpected
and number two I knew from the jump
Tarantino loves Bruce Lee he Revere's
him to mow the fight scene wasn't about
disrespecting the beloved Hong Kong
American actor it was about establishing
Cliff booth as a force to be reckoned
with
it's a hugely important scene what
better way to show how dangerous cliff
is and for him to show up and even match
him for a little bit with Bruce at that
moment when I get slammed that's when
Bruce realizes oh this guy is not just a
stunt guy because Bruce didn't always
have the most affection for stunt man he
didn't respect all of them because he
was better than all the stunt guys so
after I got slammed I get serious
know also admit said I can see how
people might think Bruce got beat
because of the impact with the car but
you give me five more seconds and Bruce
would have won and what if the fight had
really happened on the set of The Green
Hornet the real-life television series
starring Lisa Green Hornet smash driver
Kato
both things that would have motivated
Lee to continue improving as martial
arts skills I know people are going to
be up in arms about the scene but when I
went into my deep dive of studying Bruce
he more than anybody wanted people to
know he's human and I think I respect
him more knowing that he had these
challenges these obstacles just like
everybody else I don't know any actor
out there that doesn't have some sense
of wanting to be more and I think that's
the sign of somebody that wants
greatness and will achieve greatness
always wanting more nevertheless some
viewers are going to have a tough time
with Tarantino's creative choices here
as Bruce Lee biographer Matthew Polly
told The Wrap tarantino could have
achieved the same effects using bruce to
make Brad Pitt's character look tough
without the mockery Tarantino for his
part remained silent on the situation
huh just kidding you think he would sit
this one out during a film from your
press conference in Moscow the director
reminded everyone that his movies a
make-belief could cliff beat up Bruce
Lee Brad would not be able to beat up
Bruce Lee but cliff maybe could if you
ask me the question who would win in a
fight Bruce Lee or trakula it's the same
question it's a fictional character he's
a fictional character so he could be
Bruce Lee up check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]